We often hear that public universities
charge higher and higher tuition because
state policymakers have cut their
funding. Some say then the way to bring
tuition down is to bring government
funding up. Yet most research finds that
when state governments cut or increase
funding to public universities,
the effect on tuition is quite weak. One
rigorous study found that for every additional
dollar public universities received from
taxpayers, tuition declined by only 26 cents.
So where's the money going? Well
for one, a university could allocate a
budget increase to boost its own
spending on new programs and services.
In this case, funding goes up, and university
spending goes up, so tuition stays the same.
Now consider a university facing
budget cuts. One 2018 study found that
universities often reduced their own
spending instead of passing all the
budget cuts on to students through higher tuition.
The bottom line is: not all funding cuts are bad, and
not all funding increases make tuition more affordable.
What do you think is driving tuition
increases? Let us know in your comments.
Also, let us know what other topics you'd like
our scholars to cover in 60 seconds
and be sure to LIKE and subscribe for
more research and videos from AEI.